oh it's chicas birthday
yeah she's three years old three years
old three years old three years old boo
boo boo oh I love you I love you chica
Duke I love you does those words mean
nothing to you yeah chica is three years
old so today we're gonna be celebrating
her birthday and remembering all the
amazing videos that she has been a part
of where are you going chief did you
want me to hold you like a baby there's
a little better huh we support your back
with my back so yeah it is chicas
birthday so I wanted to just say thank
you everybody that has welcomed her to
the channel so much if anything she's a
bigger part of this channel than I am
and that's really saying something but I
just wanted to say you know all the fan
art of chica everything that you guys do
to support chica everything you guys
like just everything you do to help out
this dog here this is wonderful words
can't really describe how much chica has
changed my life I knew I always wanted a
dog to call my own and chica is the best
dog I could have ever asked for I had no
idea what I was getting into she is
super weird just like me and she's just
such an incredible fit into my life I
can't imagine living without her and
we're gonna have a great birthday
together
we've got cake for we've got a bunch of
gifts Amy got her stuff Amy got her a
cake and we're just gonna celebrate her
birthday all day long all right I'll let
you don't well oh that's such a good
puppy dog oh that doesn't look like I'm
petting chica right now but I I swear I
am
I swear I'm pattner good girl I can't
imagine having any other dog in my life
she has just been such a heartwarming
addition to my family she's been an
inspiration for me and she's just been
helping me and she's been there for me
and my lowest times you know any time
I'm down or sad she always knows and she
comes
she's just such a personable dog and
yeah I wouldn't be the same without it
and in that fashion I've got a few more
chicas world's video that I'm going to
post today here on the channel and I
wanted you guys to remember some of the
best videos that she's ever been in in
the description I provided some of my
favorite videos that she's ever been in
there's boat dog obviously there's chef
dog there's one of my personal favorite
videos and I think it's a lot of people
even though it's a little sad it's
called chica had surgery it's when I got
her fixed and she was so high on
painkillers that she couldn't move it
was it was really sad at the time but
every time I look back on it it warms my
heart it is such a because she's so cute
and then there's markiplier his photo
booth fun with chica chica and
slow-motion one of my favorites that was
back when she was still really shy and
unsure of where she was it was like only
the the first or second week that I got
her and then of course the first video
she was in markiplier gets a puppy where
you first get introduced and oh my
personal favorite besides boat dog all
those other ones is called chica chases
a light on the wall and almost gots it
because she is a good girl it is a
beautiful video and it's just one where
Bob and Wade were over and Bob was just
shining a light on the wall and she
could just kept going for the leg
because she loves lights cuz she's such
a good girl so anyway thank you
everybody so much I know there's been
tons of well wishes for her birthday
already and just thank you guys
everybody that's made fan art made
little gifts for her and yeah thank you
chica is such an important part of this
channel and you know she's like all of
our dog she's everyone she loves
everyone and you know I'm just happy to
have her so thank you everybody so much
for watching there'll be more cool stuff
coming today so don't worry about that
but check out some of the videos that
she's been in down in the description
and comment your favorite video that
she's been in down in the comments as
well thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye-bye